- I have to ask in "Little Miss Sunshine",
God, I love that movie.
Everyone does.
Were you really driving the car?
The van?
- Yes, that is, not there apparently.
Looks like I'm a little bored there.
That was, yeah, .
This is, you can count every
Michael Bay movie ever made.
This is the most dangerous
film ever, ever made.
We didn't have, nobody
was wearing seat belts.
- What?
- We didn't have clearance on the highway.
We just went out and they handed me,
'cause I drive in the thing.
They're like, here's the keys?
And that's
- Like, they won't even let me do that.
No one can be in the car,
and like a voicing if we're like doing
a like skit for something.
like it's such a liability.
- Yes.
- Yeah, I'm interviewing you during COVID,
on the other side of a couch right now.
Nobody is making this movie anymore.
That's my point.
- Yeah. I love that.
You just, that would've made me nervous,
driving that whole cast.
It's a solid cast, too.
- Yeah.
- So you're like, hope
I don't mess this up.
- Oh my God, there's
millions of dollars of cargo
in this vehicle for God's sake.
- I would not have liked that
pressure is what I'm saying.